let's take a look now at of the latest
pandemic developments around the world
more than 3.8 million people have been
infected with the corona virus globally
and nearly 270,000 have died a new study
by the World Health Organization
projects that up to 190,000 people in
Africa could die of koban 19 in the
first year if the outbreak is not
contained iran's state news agency has
said friday prayers will resume in
mosques in 146 cities where the
infection risk is considered minimal in
Afghanistan's national health minister
has tested positive for the corona virus
and the World Bank has approved 400
million dollars in aid to help the
country's shaky economy weather the
crisis the International Monetary Fund
is worried about an economic collapse in
Brazil the country went through a major
recession in 2016 and has just begun to
stabilize the current kovat 19 pandemic
is threatening a full recovery from up
here it all looks peaceful the statue of
Christ the Redeemer overlooking the
Copacabana but just downstairs father
Omar has to conduct mass as a life
stream as no visitors are allowed in his
Chapel the beaches are empty too the
city of Rio de Janeiro under lockdown
with tens of thousands infected with
coronavirus and 600 dying every day and
yet the government wants to shut down to
end warning of an economic collapse
arturito this idea that the economy is
less important because life is first is
not true I have always said that both of
them have to be treated responsibly the
IMF too has warned of an economic
collapse for a country only four years
out of a recession Brazil's economic
Minister is worried although we are
protected the population and everyone
has the resources what is the use of
that if within 30 days the lights go out
we're running out of food and our
national production is stopped
therefore the warning the
IMF gave is very important within about
30 days there may be shortages in stores
leading to a system of economic collapse
and social disorder with a country
worried some hope from above and a plea
for people to at least wear masks well
the corner virus crisis has also
inspired people to be more innovative to
deal with some of the challenges that
the pandemic is posed companies are
adapting to changing demands the US
company hatch exhibits has gone from
building tradeshow booths to protective
equipment for health care workers facing
a dire shortage amid the pandemic
the machines that hatch exhibits are
running again and Chris McCormick is
happy to have all his people back at
work
his company normally makes displays and
pop-up exhibition booths for clients
like YouTube or Google but all their
projects got cancelled so now they are
producing medical gowns and face shields
yeah this is one of our ep VC headgears
or halo units has an integrated clamping
mechanism for people to have a smaller
head so it's a one size fits most the
shields are quickly inserted and
installed as a keyhole registration and
it fits very comfortably you know most
people the company established just five
years ago was hit hard by the crisis
with losses running into millions of
dollars Chris McCormick tells me the
idea to rejigger his production came to
him when he was watching New York
Governor Cuomo on TV talking about the
need for personal protective equipment
the next day he was already working on
prototypes of masks and gowns together
with Morgan Fraley the last week's she
says have been a roller coaster ride
it's totally wild it feels like being in
like a world war 2 factory that has been
like a repurposed for making wartime
goods
that's what sandy would and Alex loved
for the founders of one a distilling
thought as well when regular orders for
a gin and whiskey started to dwindle
they decided to pivot their production
we had to stop producing spirits at
least for a little while
and focus all our efforts on making hand
sanitizer so it's been quite a
a big change for the business but we're
grateful both that we can find a revenue
stream from that but also that we're
able to stay busy now their distillery
produces 3000 gallons of hand sanitizer
per week mostly for first responders and
house workers in Washington DC staying
productive and creative that's also
what's important for Chris mcCormick
back at hatch exhibits he shows us his
newest product so for the little guys
you know when the doctors all done up in
there their masks and all the PPE
equipment we made versions where we
print animals on them or characters and
different faces so when they see it it's
not quite as scary as intimidating and
what we found out is it's not just kids
that need that smile right now it's
pretty much anybody hope and purpose
that's what we've got says Chris
mcCormick
as he reinvents his business model now
lockdown supposed to limit the spread of
the corona virus have reduced traffic
and pollution in some places that is
allowed nature to make a comeback in
toilet it is emboldened dolphins and
other animals to reappear dolphins
galore not far from the Similan Islands
in Thailand these magical mammals have
surrounded a Rangers boat they don't
know anything about social distancing or
the corona virus pandemic but they're
definitely benefitting from it
so there's many many people and all the
activities associated with as many
people so boat traffic partying by the
beach you know so when all this lifted
the animals tend to carry on fishermen
recently recorded these images of rare
pink dolphins a breed of indo-pacific
humpback dolphin they're around 150 of
them living in the Gulf of Thailand they
very rarely come this close to humans
nature is making a comeback starting
with some of the smallest these
leatherback sea turtles can grow up to
700 kilograms researchers now phuket are
recording the highest numbers of
newborns in over two decades the largest
sea turtles in the world bury their eggs
on remote beaches in prefer dark
features so you go towards the dark area
when they are coming up to the shore -
to lay their eggs and then they move and
head out to the lights guided by the
Stars on the way back to the to the
ocean this is a group of dugongs
sometimes called sea cows they're huge
extremely shy creatures which flee at
even the slightest hint of humankind but
with no tourists and no noise they like
many other species are currently loving
the peace and quiet